in the last couple minutes we've had an
email from Downing Street relaying
medical advice from Sen Thomas's
Hospital at number 10 spokesman said the
Prime Minister has been moved this
evening from intensive care back to the
ward where he will receive close
monitoring during the early phase of his
recovery he is in extremely good spirits
now we've had quite a lot of updates
about the Prime Minister they haven't
used the word extremely in connection
with his good spirits before so I
suspect yes there is some there is some
relief in Downing Street right now we
heard last night that he was sitting up
in the intensive care ward and and his
condition has been clearly improving but
that will be a big moment that he is
left ICU after three nights in there and
gone back to a general ward to the
relief I suspect of many he went into
hospital on Sunday night I think it was
quite a surprise for many in government
when he went into ICU on monday around
about 7 o'clock but now he is out the
recovery many ministers now expect will
take some time nobody expects him to be
back behind a desk anytime soon but the
positive progress will chair a lot of
people in Whitehall indeed it will so
moved out of intensive care back to the
ward remaining in hospital for close
monitoring and in terms of that recovery
and when he might be able to start
working again there are some big
decisions ahead but we heard from
Dominic Rob earlier didn't we that the
government's got this covered yes I
think the Dominic Rob has been choosing
his words very carefully he was asked by
the prime minister to deputize where
necessary while the Prime Minister is
effectively incapacitated you heard to
buy a cell with the Smalling claim that
the prime minister was in a state to
make decisions but they think anybody in
Whitehall actually expects that to be
enacted any time soon
Dominic Rob at the press conference this
evening making clear that he had the
authority and the ability to make any
decision coming the first of those down
the track will be towards the end of
next week when the government will
announce almost certainly a rollover of
the three week lockdown continuing on
the current terms asking people to stay
at home except where absolutely
necessary probably for around about
another three weeks Dominic Rob meeting
via videolink the national leaders of
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
today as well as in the last couple of
hours talking to opposition leaders
including Kirsten over another video
link so he is doing all of the front man
business of government but nevertheless
it simply remains a fact that Dominic
Rob is not Prime Minister he can only
deputize in areas where appropriate and
there are big decisions about lifting
the lockdown which is gonna take longer
it's gonna be a slower process because
that's gonna be weeks and months not
days that are more tricky for somebody
like the first secretary of state and
foreign secretary the two titles that
Dominic Rob hold to take there will be a
hope as some have been saying in
Whitehall that the Prime Minister might
be back in circulation by the time you
have to make those difficult judgment
calls weighing up some of the different
sort of balance and balances and demands
I'm looking at the economy and looking
at the health service that will be
necessary to lift part or all of the
lockdown but Dominic Rob yet saying
we've got it covered in a reference to
the fact that the business of government
goes on Whitehall still functioning and
meetings that need to be taken and
chaired by him will continue to be done
will continue to happen